salut il ya quelque chose que j'adorais
faire en 2016 quand j'ai lancé ma chaîne
youtube c'était de vous expliquer un
truc de mentalisme que vous seriez
capable de refaire dès la fin de la
vidéo et en parlant à loïc il a dit
pourquoi pas et là moi j'ai répondu oui
c'est pas fou du coup il a cru que
j'avais pas compris et ça c'est un autre
problème
aujourd'hui je vais débloquer un truc
dans votre cerveau qui va vous permettre
de réciter l'alphabet à l'envers comme
ça z y xwb ut srq p o n mlk jihad gfd cb
ou en prenant une lettre de chaque côté
comme ça
hasebe y cx dwf j'étais à chelsea hier j
q kpl l'om c'est quelque chose que ça
faire pas mal de mentalist et je suis
toujours étonné à quel point le public
est impressionné quand je fais ça sur
scène
viktor vincent le fait également une
vitesse assez hallucinante d'ailleurs et
à quoi ça sert
excellente question michel un rôle de
cerveau plus flexible et à maîtriser
l'information dans tous les sens oui
c'est pas fou et juste avant de passer à
la première étape prenons 60 secondes
pour parler d'un jeu vidéo qui en
partenariat avec cette vidéo aujourd'hui
bonjour je suis le professeur fabien et
j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui je
vais pas tenir l'accent d'un nouveau
remède contre l'ennui le légendaire tant
que shooter world of tanks blitz world
of tanks dit c'est un mmo
multiplateforme est gratuit pour des
combats de temps qui déchire tant
d'ennuis avec plus de 120 millions de
joueurs dans le monde s'est testé et
approuvé si vous aimez avoir le choix le
jeu propose plus de 369 véhicules
uniques exclusif de dire 370 allant des
chars historique hochart expérimentaux
d'univers un peu comme warhammer 40000
mad mats vous trouverez le temps qui
vous fera vibrer de plaisir phrase chou
bataillant cette fois 7 avec différents
modes dans plus de 25 emplacements des
évènements en jeu des événements
spéciaux comme l'invisibilité dans mac
games ou les batailles réaliste un mode
très difficile et la longitude demande
quelle est la composition de world of
tanks blitz poser la question c'est
sympa
des graphismes spectaculaires un système
de progression ultra développé un
teamplay pour créer des pelotons avec
vos amis participer à des tournois la
possibilité de changer d'armes à feu
d'équipement même de camouflage le tout
pour un gameplay compétitif stimulant
qui vous permettra d'utiliser plein de
tactique différente pour foncer vers la
victoire parce que oui on va pas se
mentir faire exploser des trucs et
détruire les chars des ennemis ça vous
envoie un sacré choc de deux familles
alors télécharger ou world of tanks ghz
via mon lit
mois ci dessous des autochtones et un
compte premium de sept jours le temps
que nouveaux cas tu as et un sentinelle
est un cadeau des banderoles sans
oublier qu'elle jusqu'au 6 mars vous
pouvez choper le défendeur mk1 vous le
voyez actuellement d'écran century de
chars britannique de rands 8 avec un
gameplay dynamique culturelle blindés et
à tambour à chargement rapide tu sais
pas ce que ça veut dire mais bientôt tu
seras bref en téléchargeant ce jeu voulu
très efficacement contre votre propre
ennuis en vous amusant gratuitement
n'importe où entre amis passer
directement par moyen de la description
ça soutient la chaîne et les autres
projets comme matière grise 1 par
exemple
étape numéro une comment réciter
l'alphabet à l'envers loïc un générique
cette étape là je vais la faire avec
vous et poissons fécond pour vous
remettre dans le contexte j'ai tourné
une vidéo sur la chaîne de poissons
fécond et il nous restait moins de dix
minutes avant que je parte pour prendre
mon train et je me suis dit si après une
journée de tournage
j'arrive à lui faire apprendre à faire
ça en speed alors c'est que tout le
monde peut le faire et j'en fais une
vidéo du coup crise ma question c'est
est-ce que tu peux me réciter l'alphabet
vite possible s'il te plait a b c d e f
g h i j k l amène au pq est resté uv w x
y z
yes on est sur un succès au challenge
bien compris le sujet de la vidéo c'est
maintenant est ce que on peut le dire à
l'envers pas forcément la même vitesse
mais au rythme que tu veux essayer de le
dire à l'envers z y wx donc déjà
inversée le hic c'est avant de w il ya
des années quand j'ai voulu apprendre à
le faire moi même j'ai dû inventer une
méthode et c'est cette méthode là que je
vous donne aujourd'hui alors l'alphabet
est composé de 26 lettres
[Musique]
merci fabien d'oriens loïc à prendre 26
lettres c'est long mais si on les
regroupe par quatre ça nous fait plus
que six choses à apprendre
on n'a pas commencé à le faire qu'on a
déjà gagné énormément de temps 24 exact
il reste donc les deux dernières lettres
b et a
je pense qu'il ya pas besoin de la
prendre pour s'en souvenir le premier
paquet à connaître ces x allez-y dit le
x mais comment on fonctionne par quatre
il faut se dire x w et si elle imaginait
mot dans votre tête voyait le et qu'ils
xwb prononcer le 2 3 fois à voix haute
et et boum c'est ancré et pour le
réciter vous pensez à 6 w et vous avez
juste à l'épaule et z y x w et là vous
venez de faire le plus dur
le deuxième paquet il et easy de fou
vous dites vue et c'est bon en fait ces
vues au pluriel
c'est super simple à retenir v u ts vue
maintenant vous connaissez xwb vu que
vous pouvez et pelé z y xwb ups
troisième paquet c'est le plus marrant
crq p o
alors j'ai un moyen mnémotechnique que
vous ne pouvez pas oublier pour hertu p
o si je mets de l'air dans le cul alors
je fais un p o
alors oui je sais c'est débile mais plus
le cerveau imagine des trucs chelous et
mieux et les retient alors vous vous
souvenez de l'air dans le cul ça fait 1
p o et visualiser rrq p o et dites le à
voix haute une ou deux fois
prenez le temps fait pose si vous voulez
et vous connaissez maintenant xwb vue et
reculée au bizet d' y xwb ut srq p o
parfait non de culot
vous connaissez maintenant la moitié de
l'alphabet à l'envers c'est énorme
la vidéo vient de commencer comme
d'habitude il suffit de les peler pour
le réciter est juste un détail
apprendre à dire une lettre du début et
de la fin de l'alphabet de a z y
sévissent des w et c est encore plus
facile et ça on verra ça après
rapidement quatrième paquet ce sont des
nems laqué name laqué nm et le cas et
voilà le nouveau paquet nml cas pour l y
xwb utc occupés aux aînés mais le cas
avant dernier paquet cjg en général les
gens ils pensent un gigot en essayant de
se rappeler que le hacher avant le g
puisqu'on fait à longueur poisson fécond
il s'est amusé à associer le nem que
l'on fourré dans le gigot et c'est
tellement bizarre que c'est une idée
excellente gigue
vous avez maintenant tête un truc chelou
mais surtout xwb est occupée au n mlk
gigue mon fusil z y xwb ut srrp qui nous
met all her hair cuts p o
nml cas ensuite on a le finish est
évidemment celui qu'on aime tous c'est j
-fh j'ai très bien vu
là ça commence à être compliqué parce
que tu l'apprends entre h et le dernier
araujo qui accroche
jeckyll trash on aime tous et avant de
passer à la toute fin on va laisser
votre cerveau digérer un petit peu pour
l'information faut qu'ils les synthétise
pendant ce temps je vous laisse la
liberté de vous abonner et d'activer la
cloche pour voir les prochaines vidéos
c'est bon moment là voilà et puis
peut-être aussi vous abonner à mon
instagram comme ça on va peut-être
atteindre les 300 mille personnes qui
voit le contenu que je fais
exclusivement pour instagram comme café
voilà et c'est déjà la fin le dernier
paquet avec fdc alors fdcc du feu qui
provoquent un décès fdc feu décès les
trois derniers paquets ça donnerait donc
un m lac et que l'on four dans un gigot
il prend feu et c'est le décès soit nml
cagibi hgf edc et bien sûr on rajoute b
à la fin pour terminer parce que
bah c'est la fin passé le film below
c'est ça on récapitule xwb vue percu p o
n mlk gigue
fdc b à z y xwb eu tsr tu paies au mm
lkj 10 h
j'ai un peu dcb à exact c'est un strike
messieurs crise merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté ce défi là dans mon décor et moi
je vais vous donner des pis si vous
voulez faire des trucs encore plus ouf
avec l'alphabet parce que c'est possible
mais pour ça on se rejoint dans mon
bureau a su créer un plaisir monsieur
oui car je vous ai féconde et le cerveau
passant l'étape numéro 2 réciter
l'alphabet en prenant une lettre du
début de l'alphabet et une lettre de
l'alphabet de l'alphabet loïc mini
générique jolie emilie génériques alors
ça c'est très rapide car à partir de la
lettre f il n'y a plus qu'une seule
chose à retenir
le but est donc à la fin de fer à z b
iréc cx dwf j'étais à chelsea hier j q
cap et l eau et mais la première étape
c'est à z b y cx des wnv c'est la
première chose à retenir
il faut retenir les lettres deux par
deux c'est beaucoup plus simple pour le
rythme alors à z c'est facile parce que
c'est logique les premières la dernière
lettre de l'alphabet grec c'est pas plus
compliqué on le voit le visualise cx
vous pouvez vous rappeler de la vieille
voiture qui s'appelait une cx donc c'est
xcom cx des w est élevé
eux sont à retenir c'est le seul effort
à faire et encore c'est très facile
quand on connaît déjà l'alphabet à
l'envers donc des wnv ce même ce même
sûrement tout seul est l'étape la plus
difficile
la suite elle est incroyablement simple
raison que c'est fait exprès cgt hs
moyens
quand j'étais à chelsea relais et toi tu
enfin away tranquille moi j'étais à
jeter jamais hausser l'exemple de crack
un peu trop vite j'étais hs hier c'est
fut est venu gth série1 dirait vraiment
que c'est fait pour ce à quoi le
prochain après à retenir cjq ça vous
pouvez trouver un moyen mnémotechnique
ou juste le retenir comme ça et après
presque un truc à retenir qui est très
facile aussi c'est que capello amène
alors capello comme maître capello la
maître capello maître capello safec apl
peau et amen
ça fait m n toi capello amène capter
l'eau et eybens s'est terminée en fait
vous venez de le faire là entièrement
s'est terminée à z b y six comme la
voiture dwg ths il est réfugié ths hier
j q et maître capello mn capello et mène
soit à z b y 6 dwf j'étais à chelsea
hier j q capello est humaine mesdames et
messieurs vous savez donc maintenant
réciter l'alphabet à l'envers comme
poisson fécond d'ailleurs je vous invite
également à découvrir sa chaîne et ses
vidéos qui sont très très intéressante
drôle instructive
vous avez un lien dans la description
vous savez dire l'alphabet à l'envers et
vous savez aussi dire l'alphabet en
prenant la première et la dernière
lettre à chaque fois et ça vraiment
c'est reste il est question en 2000 est
ce que vous aimez ce genre de vidéos si
vous en voulez d'autres baby dans les
commentaires mais dites-moi sur tout ce
que vous voulez apprendre dans les
commentaires c'est ça qui m'intéressera
le plus et si c'est pas encore fait il
vous reste quelques secondes pour l'icg
et cette vidéo et vous abonner
merci à voir le docteur beals avoir soin
de cette vidéo ce partenariat permet de
financer les projets comme matière grise
donc c'est très cool pour soutenir la
chaîne vous téléchargez le jeu
gratuitement en cliquant sur mon lien à
moi dans la description
voilà pour terminer vous pouvez regarder
cette vidéo qui vous apprendra autre
chose ou celle ci aussi qui est vraiment
très très cool
à très bientôt chao bisou à tout mignon
mignon comme une petite l'autre c'est
pourquoi une page sur le ventre pour
mettre leurs petits cailloux préféré
c'est trop mignon